almost 3 million muslims live in britain
and when it comes to investment many
adhere to islamic law which prohibits
interest
that's precluded muslims from buying
traditional government bonds but now in
a world first britain wants to issue an
islamic bond known as the cook
the bond will be based on concrete
assets such as state-owned property and
bond holders will get a share of the
profits they generate
prime minister david cameron hopes the
move will attract investors from around
the muslim world
for years people have been talking about
creating an islamic bond or sukuk
outside the islamic world but it's never
quite happened
changing that is a question of
pragmatism and political will and here
in britain we have got
both cameron has also announced a new
islamic index on the london stock
exchange listing companies that meet
islamic investment principles the city
of london is aiming to become a major
financial hub of the global islamic
economy alongside the likes of dubai or
kuala lumpur